so that leads me to this crazy question
here okay and I don't know if anyone's
asking this crazy question so brace for
impact ready when asked on the clay and
Buck Sexton show if Trump or nominee
would you consider being on the ticket
with them okay would you be on the
ticket with them you answered I will be
helpful to the country in whatever way I
can but I would not be number two or
member of an Administration I just don't
think that's the right way for me to
make the maximum positive impact on this
country you read for the question sure
if you win nomination would you consider
having him as your VP
and you know I think I think that he and
I probably share something in common
neither of us do well in a number two
position right I do expect him to be an
advisor okay but I want to learn from
those experiences where the bodies are
buried I don't want to recreate the same
wheel I want to understand get as much
of a head start and I do think he's a
patriot who cares about this country
every bit as much as I do and I believe
he will rise to that occasion and be
helpful to me as an advisor to
understand the experiences of the stuff
he's saying things he would have done
differently great I want to know that I
don't want to have to learn those
lessons myself and so that's the way I
think about it so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
foreign
[Music]